all right got it
all right thanks alex
so good morning everybody um
i think
i know everybody i'm george devlin have
agreed to chair the meeting this morning
uh councillor freeman's not available
this week so if that's okay with
everybody
we can start the meeting uh if you've
got any apologies
alex molly
i received apologies from council
freeman but i've not received other
apologies
okay thank you
um is there any declaration of interests
no
uh
and the minutes of the previous meetings
everybody happy with those minutes the
accurate record meeting
okay
thanks everybody
so
the
next item is an update in the current
situation eleanor
thanks george um so the rates um have
started to go up a little bit again this
week that they've stayed relatively
stable for about three weeks but still
much higher than we'd like so so well
over you know we've struggled to get
below 200 per 100 000 sorry below 300
per hundred thousand
and that's across the borough so we're
still seeing high numbers of cases
across the borough
we had seen a drop in our testing rates
particularly in our younger age group
and an increase in the number in the
proportion of people who are positive
so when schools reopened we were
expecting to see rates go up because um
as part of the return to school all
pupils are asked the secondary school
pupils are all asked to test twice on
that return to school and we are now
starting to see those positive cases
coming through the ones that we were
anticipating the good thing about that
testing program is that it means that
people are tested before they go back
into school and that means that they can
then be self-isolating
and not spreading the disease to other
people so we are encouraged by the the
good uptake we've got of the testing
through the testing program and again
the excellent work that our schools have
been doing to support this
um but we are we are seeing quite high
numbers of people coming through um
positive um
in in our secondary schools and and also
in some of the early years and um
young younger age groups in our
obviously all of those people apart from
people with
serious underlying conditions won't have
been vaccinated
so
at the moment um i think our rates are
higher than very much higher than where
i would like them particularly going
into the autumn
the general message is please do
continue to take care and to think about
other people maintain that social
distancing especially in places like
supermarkets because we do need
everybody to be out and about again we
do need normal life to resume but it
can't be normal life as it as it was so
do you know do think about other people
as a courtesy but whatever you think
about mask wearing it's a courtesy to
others to wear a mask so please do it do
continue to do that make sure you're
socially keep that social distance if
you are worried
absolutely you know parks are safe open
spaces are safe but do try and make sure
you know
i would be cautious of crowded noisy
indoor spaces where that it looks poorly
ventilated so if you are indoors if
you're visiting friends and so on do
keep the windows open and try and keep a
little bit of space
um
we are
a vaccination program there are still
quite a lot of people although we're
doing really well and
most people by far the majority of
people are vaccinated we still have some
pockets with lower uptake of vaccination
and we are worried about the disease
getting hold in those in those groups
the other issue we've got is
particularly pregnant women are we've
got quite low uptake rates in some areas
for pre of pregnant women so if you are
um pregnant we would strongly advise you
taking that
vaccine it is very safe
and we've seen tragically there have
been across greater manchester deaths of
mothers and babies um
it's a covet is a very very dangerous
disease in the third trimester so if
you're thinking of um
you or your partner are thinking of
having a baby if you are pregnant please
do get vaccinated as as soon as you can
um the other thing is we we're still
waiting for guidance on um both the
vaccination program for the healthy 12
to 15 year olds so children 12 to 15
year olds with underlying conditions
should go and get vaccinated now and
there's a program in place for for them
so please do
encourage anyone in that category to get
that vaccination all 16 and 17 year olds
can get vaccinated now the national
booking program is changing so that you
can book online for that and there's
walk-in centers as well for those we're
waiting for the cmo guidance on healthy
12 to 15 year olds
and for the booster program we still
haven't had guidance on who will be
included in any booster program
this autumn but the flu jab is starting
to roll out now so if you're invited for
the flu jab please go and get your flu
jab as soon as you can don't wait to see
whether you uh can get the two up the
same time because that may or may not
happen so at the moment we're really
just strongly encouraging people to
remember that flu is also very nasty
illness and um nobody's had the social
distancing last year was so good that
nobody got flu so we've had two years of
nobody having flu so our natural
immunity will be will be waning there so
please do go and get that flu jab as
soon as you can
i think that's that's it for me thanks
eleanor that's really helpful uh is
there any questions or any clarification
anybody would like
no
okay
okay uh the next item thanks for that
ernest next item's then
self isolation pathfinder update
i'm not sure if kirsten has been able to
join us yet
no
so defeat that and see if um because
they can join later in the meeting
uh so moving on to number item number
six it's the ten point plan uh
mass testing update
and are you gonna give us an update on
testing
yes thank you chair thanks
i just have a couple of points to update
you on
um so first of all um
as eleanor mentioned
trafford's secondary schools are doing
two test lateral flow tests as the
pupils return to school
and we offered support to those school
to all the schools in trafford that uh
have to do this program and are
currently supporting a number of schools
with their testing programs
including the provision of staff
training and
you know physical support from staffing
with the supervis the the supervised
testing of pupils
pupils who test positive are as per the
national guidance advised to then get a
pcr test to
confirm
and just on the second point is in
regard to lateral flow tests
um due to the availability and central
procurement activity um
people are likely to
access a variety of lateral flow tests
regardless of which route they use to
get the tests
so there are a number of tests so the
orient gene and the flow flex
are both uh 15 minute nasal swab only
tests
and the inner
kits are 30 minute throat and nasal
swabs
um at the moment they've all been
clinically evaluated and certified for
use the key advice is to follow the
instructions on the pack to avoid any
confusion they are slightly different in
how you use them
and that's the update for me
okay thanks thanks anne
um any questions from anybody on testing
no
i think i think george it's just to
reiterate that point that the um people
who've been doing the lateral flow test
for a while are probably very used to
doing the throat and nasal swab but the
the instructions for all the different
kits are all slightly different so it
really is important that people read the
instructions rather than think that they
know what they're doing with this one so
it is it is a bit different it's added a
little bit of complication to the system
so just just please do do do re-read the
ins check and double check
okay thanks thanks ernest next time um
the contract tracing and outbreak
management
would
usually be hell anything
i think it'll be kate today
thanks
thanks chair um just again a brief
update from myself um about contact
tracing
and as ellen has mentioned our activity
in the hub has increased this week with
the return of schools so we're helping
them um unpick the guidance and and
operationalize that new guidance and and
what that means to them in reality
and we have had a slightly calmer time
with businesses but we're still
proactively contacting our business
settings that have multiple cases to
offer them advice and support on keeping
their workers safe and keeping their
settings open and preventing
outbreaks
with respect to our level two contact
chasing which is the activity that we do
in-house to contact cases that the
national team haven't reached
our new team is starting to come into
post our first people have started in
the last two weeks
so we're working through induction and
very excited to have those on board
because that will free up some capacity
from the teams across the local
authority who've very
um
we've been very thankful for their
support over the course of the pandemic
and but as they're going back to
business as usual it's really good that
we've got a dedicated team coming online
so we can really focus on that level two
activity and really get the contact
racing bottomed out
over august we contacted over
390 people successfully that were
referred to us which is over 50 of the
referrals and bearing in mind these are
people that the national team have
failed to reach i think that is a huge
success but we have got lots of plans in
place to to improve that performance
even further
um and i think that's probably about all
that we need to say from contact chasing
but the hub is still there
instill supporting as required
all right
thanks a lot kate
any
questions anybody wants to ask any
clarification
no
no
uh
if we just pick up
the
vaccination and community engagement and
then we'll come back to the pathfinder
cursor so you've been able to join is
that okay if you just do these other two
items first
yeah that's fine yeah thanks
so jason do you want to give an update
on the max mass vaccination
progress
thanks chair um yes just kind of i
suppose just going over um what eleanor
um mentioned really um up to present the
um the priority cohorts as um
in trafford we've had a really really
good successful program with with high
vaccination rates
um
as we move to phase three
as is being said we've not got a
confirmed start date for the uh the
commencement of the uh of the booster
program but all the primary care
networks in trafford and are all on
board and and ready to deliver um the
the booster program
as soon as we get uh that that confirmed
and in addition to the uh the primary
care networks we've also got community
pharmacy um that are supporting the the
booster program as well
based on the um
update uptake data of vaccines we are
looking to
put additional sites into the system via
our community pharmacy provider
and those additional sites will be based
um where the um uptake has been most
challenging and so as soon as we get uh
confirmation of where those additional
sites will be we'll make we'll make that
uh we'll make that known as soon as
they're confirmed but they hopefully
will be around those areas of low uptake
and as
elena mentioned and cohort 13 the 16 to
17 year olds uh we're under underwear
with that that that
vaccination program with um walk-in
clinics uh
we're also looking to do some pop-up
clinics in both north and south
um colleges in trafford to um to to
boost uptake
along with access by the national
booking service too
the
12 to 15 core heart
12 to 15 years with additional risks
um the vaccination program to that group
is is underway
and that includes the um
the expanded
um
cohorts that are into that into that
group
and we obviously were awaiting the
national position in terms of the
healthy
12 to 15-year um um
cohort if nhs england
do come with um and ask to vaccinate
that core heart depending on the chief
medical
officers um decision but what we are
doing as a system is we're working with
all stakeholders and all providers and
across the system so that
if and when any call to vaccinate the
healthy 12 to 15 does come we're in a
position to be able to to mobilize as a
system to deliver
him to that core heart
thank you jeff all right thanks a lot
jason um
has anybody got any questions for jason
no
no
um
12 to 15 year olds are going to be
vaccinated would that be done
on a school site basis or would that
just be done through the
doctors or the pharmacist
so again the operational detail of that
um has yet to to be confirmed so we're
working with all the stakeholders to
understand if that call does come how
would that be i think i think as a
system we're saying that delivery in a
school environment is is the preferable
model and for that there'll be no doubt
the challenges
in doing that but i think as a system
across
schools across public health across
community services and and primary care
i think as a system then we also need to
work together to understand what those
challenges would be to deliver it in
those environments and and work to
deliver that so i think the default
position would be that we would we would
look to and do that via a schools
program
okay
thanks jason thanks for that linda um
nigel do you want to give us an update
on community engagement
yes uh thank you chair so uh in terms of
community engagement um the main thing i
just wanted to update you on today was
our summer program which i know i spoke
to you about the last board meeting
so the the the program was called shape
up for summer we ran it throughout
trafford for the four weeks of august it
was a really really good success we were
in each of the four neighborhoods
for a week at a time and uh there monday
wednesday friday
uh each week uh during the program we
interacted with adults children and
families to um
give out really public health
information on
healthy lifestyles signposting people to
to various services we have discussions
with people
around the code 19 vaccinations and also
how they were feeling and also we were
encouraging participation in physical
activity
and learning new skills so the
activities and conversations really well
received it was really kind of the
emphasis was on making it fun
interactive
and
in terms of numbers we engaged with over
a thousand people in the community
during that time
and around uh 400 people kind of
interacted with us in terms of giving us
feedback and around 600 people
adults children taking part in various
activities
so we've done an initial review of the
program um
how it went lots of learning that we can
use for future initiatives and the data
team are helping us to just evaluate the
findings as well but just some of the
key findings i know went through some of
these last time but just to give you
some updated figures on these so
in terms of um
vaccinations uh 77 77 people we spoke to
had had both doses of the coc19 vaccine
for those that were unvaccinated which
was only a small number uh the main
concerns were around vaccine safety and
side effects or that they had um
the concerns the vaccine might impact on
existing health conditions
uh the really encouraging thing was that
people
the vast majority of people around 90 of
people said they felt so safe and they
were glad to be out and about
um and encouragingly as well the vast
majority of people said they were still
practicing uh covet 19 kind of safe
behaviors
so what we're going to do is going to
pull together some slides with an
overview of what we did the key outcomes
of the program with the with the video
clip and we're going to put that
together
with an update on the other community
engagement work we've been focusing on
over the last three to four months and
we're going to circulate that to all
elected members so
so we'll just look out for that in the
next couple of weeks
um in terms of other activity now um the
testing team gave us great support i've
got say over that summer program and at
the moment we're now
supporting them
with the
the work they're doing at the school
testing program this week
um and the other key focus for us is
going to be around supporting the public
health team in um
you know increasing vaccination uptake
in those kind of priority areas so for
example as ellen i mentioned
earlier pregnant women that's gonna be a
focus with us and we're currently in
conversation with colleagues in the
public health and ccg on how we can
support
uh we're planning on doing some further
work in the north area particularly in
the clifford ward where we're gonna do
some further evidence-based
questionnaires and
further promotion of clinics
and the other area focuses young people
so we've been getting the messaging out
to promote
the 16 17 year olds obviously they can
now get vaccinated but
importantly where the website is where
they can find their nearest walk-in
clinic
we had a really good engagement session
last week with the youth cabinet
and uh the findings from that were fed
back to the operation team who were
planning the pop-up clinics as jason
mentioned before
and uh when any additional clinics are
confirmed we will be assisting with
engagement and support for those as well
as coordinating the uh volunteer offer
uh and then just finally i've got an
update from ellie from the comms team
which is that their focus is on firstly
implementing some outdoor advertising
uh i think it's gonna be mainly in the
north and central area to encourage
backseat up to take for the 18 to 30s
they're also going to be refreshing the
digital ad campaign for the 1830s that
were very much focused on the summer but
now that's going to be have an autumn
winter focus
and they're also going to be revisiting
and updating the resources they created
um
they created these resources a few
months ago but they now need to be
updated in terms of the changes for the
self-isolation rules so
that's the update for me thank you
thanks for that nigel um
sounds like you've got a lot going on
uh thank you
any questions from anybody anything
um it would be definitely interesting to
see the report nigel on the work that
you did in august so thanks for that
um
kirsty do you want to give us an update
on the pathfinder yeah of course thank
you
and so we are approaching the final week
of the pathfinder so it was the the plan
was to run the pathfinder for 12 weeks
um and that's proactively contacting
people
all positive cases in the m15 m16 m32
and m33 postcards
so they've all received a proactive
phone call
to
to inform them of what support is on
offer across trafford
so
um we've still got this week's figures
to come in but we have reached over 1500
individuals with that phone call
and we've provided enhanced support to
over 215 individuals through a variety
of
that might be temporary accommodation
food vouchers signposts into the
self-isolation payment signpost into
community hubs to provide a listening
ear and so a variety of things that um
providing that enhanced support
the food vouchers that we've been
offering continue to be a success
so were they being provided to those
that might not be eligible for the
financial payment or in real urgent need
of food
and and we continue to signpost and
really do some awareness raising around
the financial support that is on offer
in trafford the 500 pound grant and as a
result of that promoting it we have seen
a huge increase in the sip applications
since the pathfinder started
overall it's been very well received by
residents um even when they haven't
needed support they've been very
appreciative of the call
and and then
some other gm authorities have finished
their pathfinder so there's going to be
an external evaluation taking place in
october across all the greater
manchester local authorities and that
will feed into the national team to
hopefully inform them what's needed
around
support for self-isolation
so although the pathfinder's ending
um the general support will continue for
people across trafford um so the the 500
pound self-isolation payment people can
still apply for that and we still have
the local welfare schemes in place
through trafford assist for the food
parcels the vouchers the gas and
electricity and so just to let people
know that the support is there if people
need it
yeah
thank you thank you kirsten that sounds
again really positive is there any
questions anybody
uh counseling new rush
yeah thank you for that i'm quite
interested to know uh if there's if
you've got the data between the
pathfinder area uptake of of things like
the grant
versus the rest of trafford because it
was a very localized area um has it been
quite differential and therefore you
know you can show that this is
um i think as part of the whole
evaluation to the pathfinder so i think
us finishes on friday that's some of the
intelligence that we're going to pull
together and hopefully feed that
evaluation back in we know um that we
have seen the increase in the
self-isolation payments as a result of
promoting it but obviously there's more
to that than it just been as a result of
the pathfinder you know based on case
rates and things so hopefully the
evaluation will pick that up
thank you
thanks okay thanks kirsten
kirsty could i just ask you mentioned at
gm at a national level we'll be doing
evaluation is there is there any local
trafford evaluation where we might be
able to learn some of the lessons
through the work that
you've been leading on yeah so i think
that would probably be useful to bring
to the next pebb once the um
once it finishes this week so we can
certainly do our own local evaluation
and bring that the
the more regional evaluation is only due
to commence in october so obviously
that's going to take some time but we
can certainly bring some local stuff
back
yeah that would be helpful because there
might be some you know lessons that we
can learn quickly definitely
link in with some of the other work that
we're doing thank you thank you chair
so the next item is that just any
updates on any
board members activity
since the last meeting
anybody got anything to feed feedback
so is there any other business
i just had one well two quick ones one
was um the work that um the community
hubs continue to do um is really very
much appreciated and
obviously the work of that community of
our community engagement team over the
summer giving us a lot more insights
into into
how it's been for people in trafford and
that we'll we'll be continuing with all
of that work and the second one is this
is um kate murdoch's last meeting
um kate we borrowed kate from manchester
foundation trust a year ago and um they
have missed her badly and we have
absolutely been relying on her but she's
um she's going back to her well actually
she's had a promotion they have um
they're taking her back and they're
promoting her which is extremely well
deserved but i just wanted to note um my
thanks um to kate for all the work she's
done over the last year
yep um i think we just echoed that from
everybody else in the board thanks
eleanor for pointing it out and uh
congratulations kate i hope you've
enjoyed the years that you've spent in
trafford
and you never know we might see you in
the future
i think just picking up on uh
what you were saying eleanor about those
that sort of community activity i think
one of the real strengths of what we've
been doing over the past 12 months
has been
that real engagement with communities
and this board i think has been able to
bring a lot of that together and again
hopefully as we're moving out of
culverts if that ever happens that we
can learn some of those lessons and
really
continue to engage in the way in which
everybody's been demonstrating through
this meeting and previous meetings so
thanks for everybody so thanks everybody
for all your work
um enjoy manchester cage and the next
meeting will be i think two weeks today
which is the 22nd
so
and i hope the sun is still shining
where you are it is where i am
thanks a lot
thank you